[Music]
in practice everything went fine and
then during the audition you know the
worst possible thing happened a hint
we wanted to step up our act so we added
some new elements that we've never
worked with before with the fire and the
blindfold
because I can't see I'm blindfolded
they're cheap we have to go off the
verbal cue and so there's we have a
music cue that I'm waiting for by also
give Mary a verbal cue I was kind of
freaking out because I mean I knew I
knew right away I could feel her
slipping through my hands and that
feeling that feeling is just terrifying
I mean it was miserable I mean it's like
it felt like it lasted so long it was
really uncomfortable okay my first
thought I blacked out the audience black
top judges and instinct you know it's
just I just need to tuck my head up and
I hit and I realized that I was okay
first thing I wanted to do was get up
and let everybody else know that I was
okay because my mom was there our son
was there and I knew that Tice is
probably really worried about me so I
just wanted to show that I was okay the
worst part of that was I had a bit of a
bruise on my back they get hit and for a
minute there like it you know clean your
breath get like the wind knocked out of
you yeah so that's what I was feeling in
that moment after the horrifying stunt
mishap judge Simon Cowell had nothing
but praise for the daredevil couple she
did he broke Jeanette and the fight
young lady blind makes this incredible
Thank You Simon he did reassure ISA you
know you guys are great don't let this
you know don't let your heads hang low
this was fantastic and so they were
great they were really nice very badly
and your first thought was let me do
that again and only on America's Got
Talent does that happen
we want our routine to be as as great as
possible and and so that's kind of what
why we would have we definitely would
have gone up and done it again and
obviously it if I wasn't comfortable
dice would never make me do something I
don't want to do
[Music]
[Applause]